what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime opera and today I will be
breaking down the unique powers and
abilities of you know from black clover
and I will be delving into you know
secret origins which have finally been
revealed in the black lower story in
fact the most recent developments in
black clover have given us a lot of new
information about you know including
some important clues about you knows new
post time skip powers and his hidden
potential I can't wait to get into all
of the exciting details so let's do this
space cowboys if you enjoy the black
clover content right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
definitely helps and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar finally this video will
of course contain black hole ramanga
spoilers we're talking about all the
most recent events in the manga so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned as we recently learned in
the black horror story
despite being left at an orphanage in
the forsaken realm of the clover kingdom
as a baby you know is not in fact a
commoner or a native clove Aryan at all
Kovarian does that sound right I don't
know but the point is that you know is
actually from the Spade Kingdom in fact
you know is the Prince of the Spade
Kingdom and the rightful heir to the
Spade Kingdom throne he is the son of
the rightful rulers of the Spade Kingdom
CL and Loyce grin burial and his family
the house of gran burial was at the time
the ruling royal house of spade however
when you know was still a baby his
family was overthrown in a violent coup
d'etat orchestrated by the dark triad a
powerful trio of siblings who used
demonic powers in order to increase
their strength
so you knows parents were killed by the
dark triad during the hostile takeover
but you know was smuggled out of the
kingdom and left at the orphanage at hog
a village in order to conceal his
identity and keep him safe as the
rightful heir to the Spade Kingdom
throne
you know would always pose a threat to
the triad and if they had found him as a
baby they likely would have killed them
in order to eliminate any possible
future challenges for the throne
thankfully you know survives and grows
up as an orphan inside the forsaken
realm of the clover kingdom along with
hasta and the other orphans but despite
having a seemingly unremarkable
background as far as everyone in hog a
village is concerned you know quickly
begins to stand out due to being born
with immense magical talent we now know
that you knows incredible natural
talents are likely due to his royal
bloodline but we have to be fair and say
that growing up as an orphan along with
his rival and friend hasta you know
developed impressive willpower and
determination to succeed and these
qualities helped him become much
stronger than he would have been if he
had only relied on his natural talent
having grown up in more challenging
circumstances than other Royals you know
developed skills and characteristics
that most normal Royals would not have
the opportunity to develop the extent of
you knows willpower and determination is
demonstrated when he is able to resist
being possessed by an elf while still
being able to use the elfs magic for his
own benefit before he began his journey
to become a magic knight and eventually
the wizard king you know was chosen by a
powerful and rare 4-leaf grimoire which
contains wind-based spells you knows
magic centers around the ability to
create and control wind and he can use
this magic even without a grimoire but
the grimoire allows him to bring out the
full potential of his wind magic along
with being able to use wind magic in an
offensive way creating powerful wind
gusts and whirl winds that often take
out the enemy in one shot you know can
also use wind magic to move very quickly
including through the air needless to
say when magic is extremely fast and
versatile and the power of this magic
combined with you knows drive and
determination has created truly
incredible results using wind magic you
know can create objects and creatures
such as blades made out of wind and even
animals like birds that are comprised of
wind magic so we're not talking about
simple wind magic here we're talking
about some pretty sophisticated and
complex spells due to the immense amount
of magic he possesses you know he's able
to use the spell known as mana
skinned extremely effectively using mana
skin you know can increase his
resistance and physical abilities in
battle he is also able to use more than
one magic spell at the same time in
addition to all of his other powers and
abilities you know is able to summon
sylph
the wind spirit to help him in battle by
combining his own impressive natural
abilities with sylphs wind magic you
know he's able to increase his strength
and his ability to use complex magical
spells for example using spirits dive
you know can even temporarily absorb
silk into himself which allows him to
gain a new form and increase all of his
powers and abilities you know also
contains the child of lifts within him
and when the child awakens you know
becomes yet more powerful but
importantly he is able to maintain full
control of himself and he does not
become possessed by the elf this is very
similar to Asta's ability to remain in
control of his body and resist being
possessed by the demon inside his
grimoire while still being able to use
the demon's power so we already know
that you know is extremely powerful and
possesses a wide variety of special
skills and abilities we now also know
his secret origins as the Prince of the
Spade kingdom which explains his
incredible natural talent after all
members of royal families are well known
for their remarkable talent for magic
and so all of this brings us to the most
recent events in the black collar story
following the six month time skin after
the time script takes place and the war
between the spade Kingdom and the clover
and hard kingdoms escalates we finally
get to see the new and improved you know
in action after the headquarters of the
Golden Dawn Squad is attacked by xenon
and other powerful mages from the Spade
Kingdom when he arrives at the scene of
the attack you know realizes that half
of his comrades from the Golden Dawn
have apparently been killed while the
other half are seriously injured and
barely breathing you know is of course
furious but he doesn't have much time to
come to terms with what is happening
because he is quickly challenged by an
extremely powerful spade mage who uses
rock magic and on top of that his rock
magic is
being boosted by the power of a demon
most likely Meggie Kula it appears that
xenon isn't there because he is
currently facing off against the Golden
Dawn captain William Vaughn gents so it
is up to you know to take on the rock
magic mage the battle begins and you
know is doing his best to help his
injured comrades while dealing with the
bloodthirsty rock mage at the same time
and as the fight progresses and it dawns
on you know what actually happened it
seems to me like you know is becoming
increasingly furious you know is
normally very calm cool and stoic and it
takes a lot to upset him but after just
learning that he became an orphan
because the dark triad brutally murdered
his parents his family and now being
faced with the fact that xenon and the
Spade King the mages have killed or
seriously injured most members of his
new family the Golden Dawn squad you
know is understandably upset you know is
genuinely trying to figure out why this
rock mage and the rest of the Spade
Kingdom soldiers are attacking his
comrades but the rock mage doesn't
really provide any logical reason
apparently he just enjoys fighting and
facing off against strong opponents and
that is his whole reason for doing what
he is doing the rock mage believes that
those with strong magic power like him
and you know are meant to use it to
fight and conquer and destroy because
it's fun and makes him feel alive but
you know proclaims that he is nothing
like the rock mage at the same time you
know uses wind spirit creation magic
spirit of Zephyr in order to generate a
massive sword made up of condensed mana
the same sword that he had used in the
epic battle against the kotodama demon
as you know summons the sword something
interesting happens his left eye turns
dark considerably darker than I recall
ever seeing it before if I remember
correctly during the fight against the
kotodama demon back in chapter 2:11
Eunos left I did look slightly darker in
certain panels as he was using the
spirit of Zephyr but in Chapter two
three six while he is fighting the rock
mage from the spade Kingdom unis left
eye becomes noticeably darker than it
any point in chapter 2:11 using the
spirit of zephyr you know is able to
seemingly cut straight through the rock
mages body presumably killing him on the
spot I can't imagine how this guy could
have survived this attack and if he
really is dead then this shows that post
time skip you know is not messing around
he has had enough
he lost his birth parents and became an
orphan because of the dark triad and now
these same people have assaulted his
comrades and it looks like many of them
have been killed you know doesn't seem
to be in a forgiving mood after that and
it really looks like he just cut through
an outright killed the rock mage in
Chapter 236 unless we learn something
new in the next chapter about the rock
mange like perhaps he can detach parts
of his body and then put them back
together or something like that then it
is likely that he will go down and stay
down and it is also likely that you know
is about to go full beast mode on xenon
and the rest of the dark triad this also
makes me wonder about the extent of you
knows true potential if he has just
unlocked a new type of power whether
through the elf or some other type of
way and if he has decided that it's time
to become more ruthless against his
enemies how strong could you know
actually become we've seen how much
stronger hasta has gotten during the
time skip and how much his control of
anti magic has improved since you know
has always kept pace with hasta strength
and vice versa I expected you know
s'posed time-skip power up will be every
bit as impressive as osdas and that is
saying a lot also at this point we can't
be completely sure why exactly you knows
left I became so dark during this fight
but it could mean that post time skip
you know has been able to unlock even
more power or a new type of power this
could mean that you know is perhaps
learning to tap into more of Licht sons
Elf power although the one eye changing
color thing is more consistent with
austin's black hasta transformation than
with elf possession and speaking of
austin's transformation what's with all
the similarities between austin you know
when it comes to their transformations
why is it that the black asked the form
and you know spirit died
form are almost like mirror images of
each other with Austin's body
transforming on the right side his right
eye getting darker his right side
sprouting a wing like growth the right
side of his head sprouting a demon horn
and so on and you nose transformation
being concentrated on the left side of
his body his left eye becomes darker he
gets a wing like growth on his left side
half-a-crown manifests on the left side
of his head and so on I mean all of this
can't be just a coincidence and yet even
now that we've finally learned the truth
about you know secret origins we still
don't know why
hasta ended up in the same orphanage as
you know at the same exact time what is
the true connection between these two
I mean sure they grew up together so
they became best friends and rivals but
that doesn't explain why they appeared
at the exact same orphanage at the exact
same time and it definitely doesn't
explain why their transformations seem
to mirror each other
I am extremely curious to find out more
about Austin's origins who were his
parents and how did he end up next to
you know at the orphanage on that
fateful night is hasta also connected to
the Spade kingdom in some way do he and
you know share some sort of family
connection that we still don't know
about definitely let me know what you
guys think about Austin's origins and
his true connection to you no and why do
you think that their strongest
transformations seem to be mirror images
of each other also what do you think
about you knows new post time-skip
power does the darkening of his left eye
mean that he is unlocked a new type of
power or that he has been able to tap
into more of the elf's power within him
and beyond you know strength do you
think that what just happened with the
Golden Dawn squad will change you know
as a person will he now become more
angry and willing to kill his enemies is
the era of calm and cool you know over
please don't forget to give me your
feedback down in the comments below
personally I can't wait to see how you
nose character continues to develop in
the future and I am super curious to
learn more about the true origins of
Austin if you enjoyed this video you
want to see more black louver content
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to item
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications seriously if you don't go
through the trouble of clicking the Bell
and then checking out the option that
says all you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos it's just how YouTube works don't
forget to check me out on Twitter and
Instagram at anime outpour for all the
latest black clover news and updates and
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible with all the YouTube
problems lately patron support is more
important than ever so thank you guys so
much
special thanks to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous very dolla beat Anatole
Cassatt's kee alpha deal on hell Cruz
team Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney and Emperor otaku and I
can't forget the ones that rise above
all other clans a massive thank you to
all of our the wanna tear patrons
including in grata a Lola nada
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus and Tyson Queenie know if you enjoy
our work and you feel that it provides
value to you please consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear on our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]